benannt ist dieser azurit nach dem
ägyptischen gott der finsternis und des
chaos und das zu recht in zehn jahren
2029 soll apophis die erde um nur knapp
30.000 kilometer verfehlen
er kommt uns dann so nah dass wir ihn
sogar mit bloßem auge erkennen können
die nasa stuft den brocken als
potenziell gefährlich ein und auch space
ex-chef ihnen maske hat sich jetzt zu
apophis geäußert den nach sind wir
menschen derzeit einem massiven
schutzlos ausgeliefert wie zum science
fiction gibt's täglich spannende science
videos abonniert den kanal und aktiviert
die glocke nur dann verpasst ihr nichts
los geht's herzlich willkommen den
asteroiden 999 42 apophis mit dem
gigantischen durchmesser von 340 metern
hatten astronomie teams bereits im juni
2004 aufgespürt und schnell war klar
dass wir uns demnächst sehr sehr nahe
kommen wird zunächst ging man sogar von
einer kollision wahrscheinlichkeit von
2,7 prozent aus das ist sehr sehr hoch
was jeder 30 saß sieht mit einer solchen
wahrscheinlichkeit schlägt auf der erde
ein aktuelle berechnungen dagegen
schließen eine kollision mit der erde im
jahr 2029 aus genau genommen wird er uns
am 13 april 2029 sehr nahe kommen dann
wird apophis die erde mit einem abstand
von nur knapp 30.000 kilometern
passieren also näher als die umlaufbahn
der geostationären satelliten liegt also
vieler wetter und
kommunikationssatelliten dabei legte er
fast 40.000 kilometer pro stunde zurück
sieben jahre später also im jahr 2036
wird sich der gigantische also ich dann
wohl erneut nähern und um es noch einmal
in einer deutlichkeit zu sagen seine
geschätzte entfernung zur erde wird dann
nur 30.000 kilometer betragen das ist in
astronomische dimensionen wirklich sehr
wenig die nasa bezeichnet ihn als
potenziell gefährlich dazu führen seine
größe und seine nähe zu erde falls es zu
kursänderungen kommt und apophis doch
auf der erde einschlagen sollte würde
dies eine explosion von knapp einer
millionen tonnen tnt entsprechend klar
ist die auswirkungen wären katastrophal
doch derzeit ist die nase optimistisch
das szenario am 13 april 2029 wird sich
für uns auf der erde demnach
folgendermaßen darstellen
am 13 april 2029 streift ein licht
über den himmel er wird heller und
schneller an einem punkt wird er
innerhalb von einer minute mehr als die
breite des vollmonds zurücklegen und
dabei so hell werden wie die sterne im
kleinen wagen aber es wird kein satellit
oder flugzeug sein
es wird ein 340 meter breiter erdnahe
asteroiden namens 999 42 apophis sein
der lichtpunkt wird nasa angaben zufolge
sternförmig erscheinen und nach
aktuellen analysen zuerst über der
südlichen hemisphäre mit bloßem auge am
nachthimmel zu sehen sein dann wird er
wohl von der ostküste australiens zur
westküste hinweg rasen dann flug über
der erde hinweg führt ihn über den
indischen ozean afrika und über den
atlantik diesen wird er wohl innerhalb
von einer stunde überquert haben gegen
10 uhr ist an den lifetime wird er dann
über die vereinigten staaten hinweg
ziehen das wird dann also in deutschland
um 16 uhr der fall sei den nasa sieht
den vorbeiflug von apophis als
unglaubliche chance für die wissenschaft
dazu nasa mitarbeiter paul rodgers durch
die beobachtung von apophis während
seines vorbei flugs im jahr 2029 werden
wir wichtige wissenschaftliche
erkenntnisse gewinnen die eines tages
für die verteidigung der planeten
verwendet werden könnten
und so soll der asteroid nicht nur mit
optischen sondern auch mit
radioteleskopen beobachtet werden
dadurch könnten im besten fall sogar
oberflächen details sichtbar gemacht
werden
die nur wenige meter groß sind doch für
abruf ist wird der vorbeiflug nicht ohne
folgen bleiben dazu der astronomen
davide belotti wir wissen bereits dass
die nahe begegnung mit der erde die
umlaufbahn von apophis verändern wird
unsere modelle zeigen auch dass die
annäherung die art und weise wie sich
der hass so ingrid verändern könnte und
es möglicherweise zu oberflächen
veränderung wie kleine lawinen kommen
kann
heißt also im klartext dass ich dadurch
seine bahn und aigen rotation erheblich
verändern wird von manchen fachleute ist
jedoch eine sache ganz klar
für sie ist es nur eine frage der zeit
bis ein asteroid auf die erde trifft
auch der chef von tesla und space exil
in maske hat dazu jetzt ein statement
über twitter abgegeben
auch er bezieht sich dabei auf profis
und die fans also übersetzt in
so viel wie irgendwann ist es soweit und
ein großer asteroid wird die erde
treffen und wir haben keine verteidigung
wichtig ist es also potenziell
gefährliche hast du jeden fall genug
aufzuspüren doch da liegt die erste
große herausforderung forschungsteams
weltweit sollten potenziell gefährliche
also jedem permanent im visier haben
laut der europäischen raumfahrtagentur
esa sind es derzeit 870 objekte die den
nächsten 100 jahren möglicherweise die
erde treffen könnten
doch das klappt nicht immer so flog
beispielsweise der 2009/10 ok erst ende
juni unbemerkt an der erde vorbei
fachleuten zufolge war der fast aus dem
nichts gekommen
und dennoch ist er in einer distanz von
72 1499 kilometern an der erde vorbei
gerauscht
doch das auch spüren wenn es denn
gelingt ist nur der erste entscheidende
schritt das wirklich große problem
jedoch woanders
denn selbst wenn man hasst du ihnen
jahrelang vorher als gefährlich in den
defizit sind uns derzeit die hände
gebunden denn auch wenn forschungsteams
weltweit mit hochdruck an methoden
tüfteln eine solche bedrohung abzuwehren
oder zumindest abzuschwächen ist noch
keines davon auch nur ansatzweise
ausgereift doch die zeit spielt gegen
uns und so hat die nasa einen wirklich
krassen plan schon im oktober 2022 soll
er nach suiten mit einem gezielten
schlag aus seiner bahn geworfen werden
wir hatten darüber bei klicks um
science-fiction berichtet steht für
double es tritt wieder action testen und
die nasa will mit diesem manöver ein
spektakuläres und neuartiges asteroiden
abwehr verfahren testen
das ziel wird der er nach doppelpass mit
6 5 803 sein er wurde 1996 entdeckt und
wenig später fiel dann auch auf dass es
sich bei dem objekt um einen doppel
körper handelt deswegen sein name die
die moz die griechische bezeichnung für
zwilling der größere brocken von beiden
hat einen durchmesser von 800 metern der
kleinere einen durchmesser von etwa 150
metern
letztere wird manchmal auch als diddy
nun bezeichnet seine flugbahn änderung
soll durch die 500 kilogramm schwere
raumsonden tat ausgelöst werden die dem
nasa plan zufolge am 17 oktober 2022 mit
sechs kilometern pro stunde auf den
asteroiden treffen soll
an bord hat sie ein navigationssystem
und eine bordkamera damit sie ihr ziel
auf jeden
fall nicht verfehlt der aufprallt würde
nach den berechnungen der nasa eine
veränderung der bahn geschwindigkeit von
immun um etwa 0 4 millimeter pro sekunde
bewirken auch wenn das zunächst nach
einer minimal verändern klingt wäre
solch eine neuausrichtung groß genug um
sie mit teleskopen von der erde aus zu
messen dieses manöver wurde zeigen ob
wir mit solch einer mission tatsächlich
auch an nach soliden der sich auf
kollisionskurs mit der erde befindet
erfolgreich um zu lenken könnten
denn fest steht schon eine kleine
flugbahn änderung eines asteroiden
könnte das fortbestehen der erde
sicherstellen und andersrum eine echte
premiere denn bei dieser tat mission
geht es um die erste planetaren
verteidigungs mission überhaupt die
behörde namens planetary die fans team
der nasa tüftelt aber auch mit hochdruck
an einem anderen plan stichwort hemmer
das steht für hyper verlasse die es mit
migration mission for emergency response
vehicle auch darüber hat mir bereits
berichtet einen neuen meter langes und
knapp neun tonnen schwere raumschiff das
mit einer delta 4 heavy in den weltraum
gebracht werden soll
das könnte nicht nur als transportmittel
für eine atombombe dienen sondern auch
als rammbock beispielsweise für den
asturier benny der ist nach einschätzung
der nasa einer der gefährlichsten hast
du ihn überhaupt am 25 september 2001
135 könnte er der erde tatsächlich
gefährlich nahe kommen und das hätte mit
einem durchmesser von 500 metern und
einem gewicht von 87 millionen tonnen
fatale folgen beim aufprall wurde er
nach berechnungen der nasa wohl eine
energie von 88.000 hiroshima bomben
freisetzen das entspricht einer
genetischen energie von 1200 megatonnen
doch ein kleiner schubser könnte den
asteroiden zu einer kursänderung bringen
und selbst wenn diese erst einmal nur
minimal wäre könnte sie den kurs mit
einer gewissen vorlaufzeit im laufe der
zeit immer weiter verschieben
doch erst einmal müsste das raumschiff
gebaut werden die missionen die flugzeit
geplant werden und je mehr zeit vergeht
umso schwieriger gestaltet sich dieser
plan zehn jahre vor dem errechneten
einschlag von ben bräuchte es schon mal
bis zu 53 hemmers um seinen kurs zu
ändern oder man geht doch mit einer
atombombe gegen ihn wobei es hierbei
auch einige risiken gibt venue
könnte in mehrere teile aufgespalten
werden die dann weiterhin kurs auf die
erde nehmen auch in europa macht man
sich gedanken zum thema soliden abwehr
die esa plant ein neues teleskop auf
sizilien um den nachthimmel nach
objekten abzug ein solches teleskop
würde das innerhalb von maximal vier
nächten schaffen um den himmel in einer
nacht ab zu scannen bräuchte ist drei
bis vier solcher teleskope fest steht
jedenfalls als nächstes wird sich der
erst 2006 kv 89 der erde nähern doch
auch der wird im september wohl an der
erde vorbeifliegen
wie wahrscheinlich ist der weltuntergang
anklicken anschauen und marius
angeschrieben abonnieren bis bald bleibt
dran